[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime-doku von
Bild
9 mai 1997 kurz nach halb zwölf ein
warmer Frühlingstag in Rom die
Universität von Rom ist eine der größten
in Europa statt von einem Campus oder
Uni-Gelände spricht man von der
Universitätsstadt Sapienza die
Jura-Studentin martar und ihre Freundin
Yolanda Ricci spazieren die Straße
zwischen den Fakultäten für Statistik
Politikwissenschaften und recht entlang
sie haben keine Vorlesung sondern wollen
nur nach den Aushänge der
Prüfungskommission schauen
plötzlich hört Jolanda ein Geräusch
Zeugen sagen später es habe geklungen
als habe jemand auf eine Plastikflasche
getreten dann sagt Martha neben ihr
zusammen einen Moment glaubt Jolanda
ihre Freundin habe einen Ohnmachtsanfall
erlitten dann sieht sie das
Einschussloch in ihrem Nacken
[Musik]
hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu Tatort
Deutschland ich bin Toni Heyer mein Name
ist Mirko Kasimir hallo und herzlich
Willkommen auch von mir okay Mirko nach
deinem Intro sind wir eigentlich schon
mittendrin in unserem heutigen Fall und
Leute dieser Fall löst bei mir vor allem
eins aus und das ist ganz viel Bauchweh
und Beklemmung ja mir geht's sehr
ähnlich die Ermordung der Studentin
Marta Russo ist grausam und brutal der
Mord hat eine junge Frau ihre Zukunft
beraubt und eine Familie ins Unglück
gestürzt hat viele Leute die Welt
gebracht na ja wie eigentlich jeder Mord
ja was dieser Mord aber von praktisch
allen anderen Morden unterscheidet das
sind die Umstände und die Täter und das
Motiv oder eben auch nicht
das klingt jetzt ein bisschen kryptisch
aber keine Sorge liebe Hörer das wird
gleich viel klarer
Marta Russo die ein Unbekannter Schütze
am helllichten Tag in der
Universitätsstadt nieder schießt wird
sofort in eine nahegelegene Klinik
transportiert die Ärzte können ihr nicht
helfen eine Kugel ist hinter ihrem
linken Ohr in den Schädel eingedrungen
und dort zersplittert am 13 mai 1997
Martas 22 Geburtstag stellen die Ärzte
den hirntot Fest einen Tag später bitten
ihre Angehörigen darum die
lebenserhaltenden Maschinen abzustellen
Marta Russo wird für Tod erklärt und
niemand weiß wer auf sie geschossen hat
und vor allem warum
martha ist beliebt sie lebt in einer
glücklichen Beziehung sie ist nicht
besonders politisch engagiert weder sie
noch ihre Familie haben tot Feinde
niemand kann sich vorstellen dass jemand
sie so hassen könnte dass er ihren Tod
will Spurensicherung und die Autopsie
des Opfers bringt kaum Licht ins Dunkel
die Kugel hat die Studentin in den
Nacken getroffen das ist ein be welcher
Körperteil der ist unmöglich macht die
genaue Richtung zu ermitteln aus der der
Schuss kam alles hängt davon ab ob sie
den Kopf in diesem schrecklichen Moment
geneigt hatte ob sie ihre Freundin
Jolanda angeschaut oder eben in die
andere Richtung geguckt hat wo niemand
wirklich eine Erklärung hat gedeihen die
Spekulationen war es ein Mord der Roten
Brigaden also vereinfacht gesagt der
italienischen RAF aber der einzige
Hinweis darauf ist dass die Roten
Brigaden an einem anderen neunten mai
nämlich 1978 den italienischen
Ministerpräsidenten Aldo Moro ermordet
haben ziemlich schwache Verbindung und
der Mord an einer einfachen Studentin
passt gar nicht ins Profil der
Terrororganisation diese Theorie kann
schnell verworfen werden waren es
rechtsextreme die wahllos getötet haben
um Unsicherheit zu sehen und den Staat
zu destabilisieren
war es schließlich sind wir in Italien
die Mafia war es ein islamistischer
Attentäter es wird in alle Richtungen
ermittelt alles erweist sich als
Sackgasse auch eine Beziehungstat wird
schnell ausgeschlossen die Beziehung war
glücklich und harmonisch und Martas
Freund hat ein glaubwürdiges Alibi
ein bisschen realistischer scheint die
Theorie dass der Schuss gar nicht Marta
sondern ihrer Freundin Yolanda galt denn
ihr Vater ist Gefängnis Direktor und es
ist nicht ausgeschlossen dass ein
ehemaliger Insasse auf die perverse Idee
kommt sich an ihm zu rächen indem er
seine Tochter ermordet und Yolanda
berichtet von unheimlichen
Telefonanrufen in den Wochen vor der Tat
jemand habe wiederholt angerufen und
aufgelegt wenn Sie das Gespräch an doch
auch diese Spur führt ins Leere mit
Hilfe einer neuartigen dreidimensionalen
laservideokamera einem 3D-Scanner zur
Vermessung von historischen Gebäuden
kann schließlich ein Modell erstellt
werden auf Basis dessen ballistiker
berechnen dass der Schuss entweder von
einem der Toilettenfenster im
statistikgebäude oder von einem Lesesaal
im zweiten Stock der Abteilung für
rechts Philosophie abgegeben worden sein
muss wir müssen gleich dazu sagen dass
diese Analyse umstritten ist wie auch
der ganze Fall bis heute
er gilt als gelöst die Täter wurden
gefasst aber nicht weniger halten das
für ein Justizirrtum dazu trägt auch die
nächste wichtige Spur bei die sich aus
der 3d-analyse und den Berechnungen der
Experten ergeben hat an einem
Fensterbrett des Lesesaals von dem aus
möglicherweise geschossen wurde werden
Schmauchspuren von einer Waffe gefunden
ja wenn man das so formuliert klingt es
natürlich ziemlich eindeutig tatsächlich
werden aber nur ein paar kleine Spuren
gefunden die vom abfeuern eine Waffe
stammen können oder so stellt sich im
Laufe der insgesamt drei
Gerichtsverfahren heraus von Autoabgasen
oder anderen Verschmutzungen später
findet man ähnliche Spuren auch an
zahlreichen anderen Fenstern die
Ermittlungen Kreisen ab da jedoch um die
etwa 25 Personen die regelmäßig Zugang
zu diesem Raum haben die Studenten
nutzen ihn um Fachliteratur zu lesen und
am Computer zu arbeiten doch als erstes
stoßen die Ermittler auf Maria Chiara
Lipari sie ist Doktoranden und Tochter
eines Professors und ehemaligen
Parlamentsabgeordneten
telefonaufzeichnungen beweisen dass die
zur Tatzeit im Raum war Maria Lipari
will sich anfangs nicht Richter erinnern
können spricht Waage von mehreren
Personen die sich im Raum aufgehalten
haben doch schließlich nennt sie zwei
Namen den von Professor Bruno Romano dem
Direktor des Instituts und den der
Sekretärin gabrieller aleto endlich
machen die Ermittler Fortschritte ja so
kann man es nennen man kann auch sagen
dass sie in ihrer Verzweiflung und unter
dem Druck der Öffentlichkeit sich nicht
mehr allzu sehr um Rechtsstaatlichkeit
und fernes kümmern
Gabriele aletto wird massiv unter Druck
gesetzt
man geht davon aus dass sie die Tat
gesehen hat nun soll sie die Täter
nennen in stundenlang Verhören droht man
ihr sie selbst wegen Mordes zu verhaften
und verspricht ihr sie werden nie wieder
aus dem Gefängnis kommen ihr Schwager
selbst Polizist kommt zur Vernehmung
dazu und rät ihr sie solle Verdächtige
nennen auch wenn sie vielleicht nichts
genaues gesehen habe ihr werden Aussagen
in den Mund gelegt oder im Munde
verdreht bis sie schließlich
zusammenbricht und zwei Täter nennt
die wahren Täter oder zwei Justizopfer
die aufgrund fadenscheiniger Indizien
und erpresster Aussagen der
Öffentlichkeit zum Fraß vorgeworfen
werden um vom Versagen der Polizei und
der Staatsanwaltschaft abzulenken aber
bevor wir über die beiden Reden Mirko
glaubst du an den perfekten Mord
ehrlich gesagt nicht weißt du warum weil
ich glaube das ist nicht den perfekten
Mörder gibt egal wie gut du denkst dass
du so eine Sache vorbereitest oder wie
genial dein Plan zu sein scheint jeder
macht Fehler und niemand ist in der Lage
jeden noch so dummen Zufall Voraus
berechnen zu können ich glaube sowas
gibt's nur in Filmen ja das geht mir
ganz ähnlich ich schätze dass die
meisten unaufgeklärten Morde nicht
darauf zurückzuführen sind das irgendein
Genie sie so gut geplant hat sondern
eher das Ermittlungen na ja ich will
nicht sagen schlampig aber ich meine in
Ermittlungen gibt es Fehler und die
sorgen dann vielleicht dafür das andere
wichtige Spuren vernachlässigt werden
oder dann eben erlischen und das
Ermittlungen auch ins Nichts führen
können und das unglückliche Zufälle die
Aufklärung verhindern Giovannis katone
und Salvatore Ferraro sehen das ein
bisschen anders die beiden sind 29 und
30 Jahre alt und arbeiten als Juni
Dozenten in der Rechtsphilosophie der
Universität sie stammen aus gutem Haus
haben eine glänzende Karriere im
Justizapparat vor sich und sie teilen so
hört man eine auffällige Faszination für
den perfekten Mord und wenn Gabriella
aletto die Wahrheit sagt dann haben die
beiden versucht diesen umzusetzen
Werbung
wir kriegen ja immer wieder Fragen von
euch rein was ihr denn eigentlich
abgesehen von Podcast zu machen was ihr
so privat anstellen ob wir da auch
andere Interessensgebiete haben und ich
sage ganz klar nein in meiner Freizeit
verbringe ich gerne viel Zeit vom
Fernseher irgendwie True Crime Dokus
Krimis etc ich bin ein ganz großer Doku
Fan und Marktes halt wenn ich irgendwie
nach einem stressigen Tag nach Hause
komme oder aus dem Studio gehe und mit
einem Abend irgendwie mich von der
schönen Doku berieseln lasse oder sogar
ich gebe ein bisschen Trash TV schauen
ja bei mir ist das Problem ein bisschen
dass ich überhaupt gar keine richtigen
Sender habe das heißt ich kann halt
wirklich nur über Apps oder Mediatheken
gucken und wenn ich halt so richtig
Fernsehprogramm will muss ich halt zu
meiner Tante rüber in die Wohnung bei
mir ist das eigentlich ich habe einen
Fernseher zum Glück ja ich muss nicht zu
meiner Tante oder zu meinem Onkel gehen
ich habe einen Fernseher mit Sendern bei
mir ist halt nur das Problem dass es
dann manchmal Streit was heißt Streit
aber dann gibt's halt manchmal
Diskussion darüber was man denn gerade
sehen will ja der eine möchte dass der
andere das und du geht es hin und her
also der berühmte Streit um die
Fernbedienung genau den könnt ihr euch
aber ersparen denn mit o2 TV könnt ihr
ganz einfach übers Internet schauen da
findet ihr über 130 TV-Sender in HD und
ihr könnt auch bis zu 100 Stunden an
live Sendungen Serien und so weiter
einfach aufnehmen oder Filme anhalten
und später weiterschauen und das gute
ist Mirko ihr müsst euch nicht mehr
prügeln was ihr gucken wollt denn mit o2
TV funktionieren bis zu vier
unterschiedliche Geräte gleichzeitig und
das nicht nur zu Hause sondern auch
unterwegs und das beste o2 TV gibt es
jetzt sogar inklusive Netflix das ist
natürlich ein super Angebot denn ich bin
ja ein riesengroßer Rick und Morty Fan
und auch die Office das sind beides
Serien die bei mir in meiner Netflix
watch liest ganz ganz oben stehen ich
werde immer in meinem Freundeskreis ein
bisschen gehänselt dass ich noch nie
diese US-Serie shameless gesehen habe
die gab es aber bisher noch nicht auf
Netflix seit dem 1 September haben sie
alle 11 Staffeln drauf geballert und das
sage ich dir am nächsten Wochenende wird
da richtig durchgesucht also falls ihr
die Serie auch noch nicht kennt als es
eure Chance guckt ihr euch mal unbedingt
an also Bucht jetzt o2 TV für günstige
9,99 € im Monat und erhalte 12 Monate
Netflix geschenkt geht dafür einfach auf
o2.de/go2/ Tatort also o2.de/got
/ Tatort TA t o r t und sichert euch mit
o2 TV und Netflix das Beste aus live
Fernsehen und Streaming als Paket alle
Infos und den link zum Angebot den
findet ihr auch in unseren Shownotes und
ihr wisst ja Leute o2 Kendo
Werbung Ende
auf alle Fälle ist es die perfekte
Geschichte vor kurzem erst haben sie ein
Seminar gehalten indem sie sich geradezu
besessen vom perfekten Mord gezeigt
haben sie beginnen ihren Vortrag so
sagen ist Zeugen mit den Worten es ist
unmöglich einen Mord aufzuklären wenn
der Täter kein Motiv hat und wenn die
Tatwaffe nie gefunden wird
ist es also denkbar dass diese beiden
jungen ehrgeizigen Männer aus purer
Neugier aus intellektueller
Überheblichkeit und krankhaftem Ehrgeiz
versucht haben diese These zu beweisen
wurde Marta Russo gerade deshalb zum
Opfer weil die Mörder keinerlei Motiv
hatten sie zu töten und sie auch
überhaupt gar nicht kannten haben zwei
Männer die sich zur Elite zählen und
Glauben über den gewöhnlichen Leuten
ihrem Recht und ihrer Moral zu stehen
ohne Skrupel einen aus ihrer Sicht
entbehrlichen Menschen getötet der tun
sich unglaubliche menschliche Abgründe
auf und naja wie schon gesagt eine
perfekte Horrorgeschichte auf die sich
die Presse verständlicherweise mit
Begeisterung stürzt schnell tauchen
Indizien auf die die beiden belasten
oder zu belasten scheinen z.B findet man
bei einem der beiden von ihnen Ausgaben
von nietzscheiss also sprach Zarathustra
jenes Werk des deutschen Philosophen
indem er den Übermenschen definiert als
jemanden
der sich über die normalen Menschen und
ihre morale erhebt bei der Durchsuchung
der Wohnungen der beiden finden die
Ermittler auch mehrere Bücher über
Serienmörder allerdings studieren die
beiden ja auch Philosophie und recht
also Bücher von deutschen Philosophen
und über Verbrechen sind jetzt nicht
gerade eine Smoking Gun also ein echter
Beweis
apropos Smoking Gun was man nicht findet
ist die Tatwaffe aber in den Augen der
Öffentlichkeit und der
Staatsanwaltschaft wird dass er zu einem
Indiz für ihre Schuld klingt logisch es
gibt kein Motiv und die Tatwaffe wird
nicht gefunden das war ja genau ihre
Rezept für den perfekten Mord ja aber
irgendwie haben sich da doch ein paar
komische Zutaten in das Rezept gemischt
zum Beispiel waren ja zum teilzeitpunkt
mehrere Personen im fraglichen Raum ich
muss sagen wenn ich den perfekten Mord
war üben wollte würde ich eher darauf
achten dass keine Zeugen anwesend sind
warum reicht es kommt mir auch komisch
vor allerdings heißt es die Angeklagten
hätten in Ihrem Seminar auch gesagt dass
Zeugen nie ein Problem sein da sie sich
unweigerlich in Widersprüche verwickeln
würden und auch das passiert ja im Laufe
der Ermittlungen und das Prozesses
insbesondere die Aussagen von Maria
Chiara Lipari und natürlich Gabriela
aletto sind in sich widersprüchlich und
nicht miteinander vereinbar und in
Teilen nachweislich inkorrekt die
belastenden Aussagen von Gabriella
können zudem im Prozess nicht verwendet
werden nachdem ein Video von einer ihrer
Vernehmungen auftaucht in diesem Video
wird deutlich wie sie unter Druck
gesetzt wurde eigentlich hat die
Staatsanwaltschaft so gut wie nichts
außer der perfekten Geschichte über den
perfekten Mord
doch auch die ist bei Lichte betrachtet
nicht so klar wie sie scheint denn die
beiden haben nie ein Seminar über den
perfekten Mord gehalten wie es nun
überall dargestellt wird der Professor
dem die beiden Doktoranden unterstehen
gibt an dass er über alle
Unterrichtsinhalte entschieden habe und
in dem Seminar sei es keineswegs darum
gegangen wie man den perfekten Mord
verübt sondern um
Verteidigungsstrategien in Prozessen ja
selbst habe in einer Lektion erklärt
wenn ein Angeklagter nie eine Waffe
besessen hat keinen Grund zum Töten
hatte und nicht am Tatort war ist er
wahrscheinlich nicht schuldig
eine kurze Passage innerhalb eines
einstündigen Vortrags aber natürlich
kann es sein dass der Professor nur zwei
seiner lieblingsstudenten decken will
der Prozess findet unter riesiger
öffentlicher Anteilnahme statt die
Verhandlungen werden im Radio übertragen
und jeder hat eine Meinung das Land ist
gespalten zwischen denen die an die
Schuld der beiden Doktoranden glauben
und denen die sie für unschuldig halten
das Gericht befindet sie jedenfalls für
schuldig so ganz scheint es seinem
eigenen Urteil aber selbst nicht zu
trauen in insgesamt drei Verfahren die
sich bis 2003 hinziehen wenn die beiden
zu siebeneinhalb bzw 5 Jahren und 8
Monaten verurteilt wegen fahrlässiger
Tötung moment mal aber das scheint ja
nun gar keinen Sinn zu ergeben entweder
die beiden sind unschuldig oder eines
grausam Mordes schuldig sollte man
zumindest meinen aber das Gericht legt
sich auf eine Version der Ereignisse
fest nach der die beiden am Fenster mit
einer Waffe herumhantiert haben sollen
wobei sich versehentlich ein Schuss
gelöst habe
ach ich weiß nicht klingt für mich
seltsam wir können hier natürlich nur
spekulieren also bitte nimmt das als
unsere Meinung und nicht als die
objektive Wahrheit für mich klingt das
aber irgendwie ein bisschen als habe das
Gericht sich nicht wirklich entscheiden
können und versucht allen gerecht zu
werden ja aber ich meine sowas gelingt
selten ehrlich gesagt ich habe gar keine
wirklich endgültige Meinung zu dem Fall
die Geschichte von den skrupellosen
karrierejuristen die kaltblütig Morden
um ihre Idee eines perfekten Mordes zu
beweisen das klingt für mich weiß ich
nicht das klingt zu durchdacht vor allem
ich frage mich wenn sie es beweisen
wollen dann darf er eigentlich niemand
wissen und damit ist es nicht bewiesen
also Sie können sich eigentlich nur sich
selbst beweisen ja andererseits Toni
gibt es natürlich die finsteren Abgründe
der Seele ob nur da oben oder hier unten
es gibt Menschen die überhaupt kein
Problem damit haben aus nichtigen
Gründen zu töten
ja wir wissen es einfach nicht Mirko ich
bin ziemlich oft ziemlich froh dass ich
keine Richterin bin und durch einen
Fehler entweder ein Mörder freilasse
oder einen Unschuldigen einsperren
könnte ja sicherlich kein einfacher Job
aber Toni lass uns doch noch mal für
einen Moment annehmen dass die
Geschichte so stimmt wie sie meistens
erzählt wird okay also dass die beiden
beweisen wollten dass das perfekte
Verbrechen möglich ist tja liebe Toni
dann haben sie aber eigentlich nur
bewiesen dass es eben nicht möglich ist
wenn die beiden andererseits unschuldig
waren dann haben wir es doch mit dem
perfekten Mord zu tun genau in dieser
Aufzählung was ein perfektes Verbrechen
braucht fehlt nämlich noch was denke ich
es darf kein Motiv erkennbar sein die
Tatwaffe darf nicht gefunden werden und
ein Unschuldiger muss ins Gefängnis
wandern damit der Fall als abgeschlossen
gilt
puh also ich glaube über diese
Geschichte kann man wirklich ewig
nachdenken und recherchieren und lesen
und viele Stunden diskutieren
hundertprozentig wissen was passiert ist
werden wir wahrscheinlich nie aber dazu
kommt natürlich ein ganz wichtiger Punkt
denn die Ermittlungsverfahren die zur
Aufklärung von solchen Verbrechen die
ihnen die entwickeln sich ja auch
ständig weiter bestes Beispiel
DNA-Analyse und wer weiß was da in den
nächsten Jahren Jahrzehnten noch alles
möglich sein wird ja vollkommen es gab
übrigens mal ein ganz ähnlichen Fall in
den USA
1924 haben zwei Studenten nächsten
Leopold Junior und Richard glaub ein
zufällig ausgewählten Teenager ermordet
um zu beweisen dass sie den perfekten
Mord begehen könnten dazu haben wir
übrigens auch schon eine Folge gemacht
wenn ihr die euch mal reinziehen wollt
dann such doch hier im Feed einfach nach
das perfekte Verbrechen auf jeden Fall
eine Empfehlung wert Toni wollen wir zum
Schluss vielleicht noch eine andere
Geschichte
ja definitiv ich finde es ja immer ganz
nett wenn wir am Ende noch so einen
kleinen positiven Aspekt reinbringen
können das ist oft wirklich nur ein ganz
ganz kleines Lämpchen in einer ganz
tiefen dunklen Höhle aber immerhin naja
positiv naja
1994 drei Jahre Format hast tot wurde
der siebenjährige Nicolas green aus den
USA während eines völlig aus dem Ruder
gelaufenen Raubüberfalls auf einen
Juwelier im Auto seiner Eltern von einer
Kugel in den Kopf getroffen und getötet
okay ich muss sagen positiv klingt an
dieser Stelle etwas verrückt aber passt
auf der Tod von Nicolas green war
selbstverständlich eine schreckliche
Tragödie was ihn so besonders macht ist
dass die Eltern die Organe ihres Sohnes
spendeten drei Teenager und zwei
Erwachsene konnten durch sie gerettet
werden zwei weitere Menschen erlangten
durch Hornhauttransplantation ihr
Augenlicht wieder diese Fall erregte
Ries alles Aufsehen denn Italien war zu
diesem Zeitpunkt Schlusslicht in Europa
was die Zahl der Organspenden anging und
dank dieser Geste der Eltern des kleinen
Nicholas die in ihrer schrecklichen
Trauer dennoch an andere Menschen
dachten an die Landsleute der Mörder
ihres Sohnes begann sich das zu ändern
und Marta Russo gehört zu denen die
diese Geschichte stark beeindruckt ihren
Eltern erklärt sie dass sie im Falle
ihres Todes auch ihre Organe spenden
Wolle und als das Unvorstellbare
passiert respektieren Martas Eltern
ihren Wunsch fünf Menschen können der
Folge ein lebensrettendes Organ
transplantiert werden das hat die Trauer
ihrer Eltern und ihres Freundes
natürlich nicht geringer werden lassen
aber andere Familien vor einem ähnlich
schrecklichen Verlust bewahrt und so
uneinsichtig die Italiener im Mordfall
Marta husso über die Schuldfrage sind in
einem sind sich alle einig martha ist
eine Heldin
und damit sind wir am Ende unserer
heutigen Ausgabe angelangt wir danken
euch fürs zuhören und bei der
Gelegenheit wollen wir uns ganz kurz
bedanken bei den zahlreichen Zuschriften
die wir bekommen also über Instagram
oder per E-Mail dabei geht ein shoutout
an Julia und Karin ganz besonders
herzlichen Dank auch für eure
Inspiration und wenn ihr fallvorschläge
habt schreibt uns gern wir freuen uns da
immer sehr darüber schreibt uns gern bei
Instagram oder per E-Mail für die
heutige Ausgabe haben wir unter anderem
auf Archivio Punkt agi.it
zurückgegriffen wir danken euch fürs
zuhören und freuen uns wenn auch beim
nächsten Mal mit dabei sein euer Mirko
und eure Ton